رينادويه من لبنان شو القصه ليه زعلانين
اللبنانيه بيوم الصحه النفسيه
صباحو
[موسيقى]
احزنتينا بهذا الخبر يعني الشعب اللبناني
كان دائما معروف بحبه للحياه وانطلاقه حتى
في اصعب الظروف يعني ايام الحرب الاهليه
ان شاء الله يتعافى كل الشعب اللبناني
ويعود لطبيعته المحبه للحياه عنا خبر ثاني
موضوع ثاني بيتعلق بالامتحانات ايضا
والاضرابات وللاسف برضو مش كثير صار من
لبنان شو التفاصيل
طبعا طبعا راويه يعني الامتحانات الرسميه
على الابواب على قاب قوسين او ادنى حتى
شهر يفصل عن الامتحانات التي لطالما كانت
محطه مفصليه بالنسبه للطلاب في لبنان طبعا
العام الدراسي لاحقه الكثير من التعثرات
وليس هذا العام فقط خلال الاعوام الاربعه
الماضيه هذا ما اثر على جوده التعليم بشكل
عام ولكن الامتحانات قائمه سوف تراعي هذا
التعثر الحاصل الحاصل والذي يعني الضرر
الاكبر منه هو لطلاب المدارس الرسميه وهنا
ستراع ظروفهم ولن يكون هناك يعني تقييم
جدي كبير
لقدراتهم بل يعني نوع من الافادات لفتح
طريق العمل امامهم
والاقدام على المستقبل اشير هنا ان البنك
الدولي يشير الى ان كل سنه تعليم فعاله
تكسب الفرد 10,000 دولار
داخل ثانوي على مدى حياته من هنا يعني على
الحكومه اللبنانيه لعدم خساره مليارات من
المداخيل الفرديه للاشخاص القيام بتحسين
للمستوى التعليمي وخاصه في المدارس
الرسميه التي هي من نصيب الاقل حظا
لاعطائهم فرصه لتحسين حياتهم فيما بعد
يعني جائحه كورونا والازمه الاقتصاديه
كلها اثرت على جوده التعليم ولكن النهوض
في بلد لطالما عرف بمناره الشرق اصبح
ضروره في هذه الظروف نعم شكرا رينادويهي
من بيروت يعطيك العافيه لم
تابعه الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات